ننوه مشاهدينا لهذه الاخبار العاجله على
شاشتنا نائب رئيسه الهيئه الاعلاميه
لانصار الله الحوثيين يقول ان هنالك غارات
معاديه تقع الان على مدينه الحديده
اليمنيه اذا نائب رئيس الهيئه الاعلاميه
لانصار الله الحوثيين يقول ان غارات
معاديه على مدينه الحديده اليمنيه قد بدات
بالفعل طبعا هذا ياتي بعد ما اعلن عنه
البنتاجون الامريكي انه وضع خطط للهجوم
على مواقع للحوثيين في اليمن على خلفيه
الهجمات في البحر الاحمر ومضيق باب المندب
على السفن المتجهه لاسرائيل قال البنتاجون
بالفعل انه اعد خطط لتوجيه ضربات لهذه
الاهداف ردا على الهجمات على خطوط الشحن
التجاري في البحر الاحمر صحيفه ول ستريت
جورنال ايضا الامريكيه نقلت عن مسؤولين
غربيين قوله ان الاهداف المحتمله هي مواقع
اطلاق صواريخ ومسيرات تابعه للحوثيين
وابلغ المسؤولون الامريكيون مسؤولين في
مجال الشحن البحري ان الاهداف ستكون حول
محافظتي الحديده وحجه الان يقول نائب رئيس
الهيئه الاعلاميه لانصار الله الحوثيين ان
هنالك غارات على الحديده ومراسل الجزيره
يرصد لنا في هذه اللحظات اربعه انفجارات
عنيفه في العاصمه اليمنيه ايضا في العاصمه
صنعاء يعني حديث وسائل الاعلام كان عن
الحديده وحجه الان نرصد من صنعاء اربعه
انفجارات عنيفه في العاصمه اليمنيه رصدها
مراسل الجزيره قبل قليل كان العقيد بات
رايدر المتحدث باسم البنتاجون قد قال ان
القوات الامريكيه والبريطانيه تمكنت
بالفعل من اسقاط مسيرات وصواريخ اطلقت
باتجاه ممرات شحن دوليه في البحر الاحمر
اذا ننوه مره اخرى الى الاخبار العاجله
اربعه انفجارات عنيفه في العاصمه اليمنيه
صنعاء وفق مراسل الجزيره وايضا غارات على
الحديده وفق نائب رئيس الهيئه الاعلاميه
لانصار الله
الحوثيين صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه كانت
قد قالت ايضا ان رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
ريشي س هناك وافق بالفعل على شن ضربات
عسكريه جويه بريطانيه على مواقع عسكريه
للحوثيين واشارت الى ان مناقشات الحكومه
البريطانيه استمرت ايام بشان الاهداف التي
لا يؤدي ضربها لحرب شامله التايمز
البريطانيه كانت قد توقعت كذلك ان ترسل
بريطانيا مقاتلات تايفون المتمركزه في
قبرص للمشاركه في هذه الضربات المتوقعه
هنالك تقارير اعلاميه اخرى تحدثت عن انه
جرى بالفعل بحث خيارات ضرب قواعد الحوثي
عبر صواريخ توماهوك من غواصات
بريطانيه اذا ننوه مره اخرى للاخبار
العاجله رويتر نقلا عن مصادر تقول ان
امريكا وبريطانيا بدات بالفعل شن ضربات ضد
اهداف للحوثيين في اليمن اذا وفق رويترز
الولايات المتحده وبريطانيا بدات بالفعل
شن غارات وضربات على اهداف للحوثيين في
اليمن وفق رويترز مراسلنا في صنعاء اكد
وقوع اربعه انفجارات على الاقل في العاصمه
اليمنيه صنعاء ونائب رئيس الهيئه
الاعلاميه لانصار الله الحوثيين تحدث عن
غارات على الحديده ايضا هذا هو نطاق اذا
الغارات
الان الحديده كما اعلن الحوثيون ا رويترز
حينما نقلت عن مصادر قالت ان الولايات
المتحده وبريطانيا بدات بالفعل شن هذه
الضربات لكن لم تذكر رويترز اين بالتحديد
مراسلنا في صنعاء قال ان هنالك اربعه
انفجارات في صنعاء وهنالك ايضا غارات على
الحديده وفق الحوثيين انفسهم